Okay, guten Tag.
Gehört, das ist mein Name.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihren persönlichen Daten notieren.
Danach besprechen wir Ihre Beschwerde, okay?
Gerne klar.
Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiße Manfred Müller.
Also könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen burschstabieren?
Ja, Manfred. M-A-N-F-R-E-D. Manfred.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Also, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Könnten Sie mit Ihren Geburtstaten genau sagen?
Also, ich bin geboren am 13. März 1946.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.
Wie sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Müller?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Söhne, ja.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Sind Sie schon Inlettegängern?
Ja, ich bin schon berendet, ja.
Aber wenn Sie mich so fragen, ich war Ingenieur.
Okay. Also, Herr Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, ich habe seit ungefähr fünf Tagen Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Und mir tut die rechte Planke so weh.
Rechte Planke.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, sind sie sehr brennend?
Oder wie?
Also, beim Wasserlassen ist es brennend.
Ja, das brennt sehr, sehr stark.
Aber die Schmerzen an der Flanke, die sind so teilweise stechend,
teilweise fast schon krampfend, muss man sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie nur Schmerzen in rechten Planke, ja?
Und sonst strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Also, ich merke, wenn das da in der Flanke weh tut,
dann habe ich das auf der rechten Seite bis in den Leiste hinein.
Mehr aber nicht.
Okay.
Also, gibt es etwas,
was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Lindern.
Nee, ich habe bisher nichts versucht.
Ich bin deshalb zu Ihnen gekommen, ja.
Ich habe gedacht, das geht vielleicht weg,
aber das ist mehr geworden und nicht weniger geworden.
Sind die Schmerzenlage abhängig
oder mit dem Bewegung lindert die Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, nein, überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
0, keine Schmerzen, 10, steige Schmerzen sind.
Also, so stark sind sie nicht.
Ich würde sagen, du bei 4, 5.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon mal solche Schmerzen gehabt?
Früher habe ich das nicht gehabt, ne?
Das ist das erste Mal.
Das erste Mal.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Gehen Sie wieder weg.
Also, jetzt seit 2 Tagen habe ich die Schmerzen immer.
Und vorher waren die immer wieder mal da
und sind immer wieder mal weggegangen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzte Zeit erbrochen?
Nee, erbrechen habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich schätze mal,
es ist ein bisschen warm.
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefallen,
dass in der Urin Ungewöhnliches gibt es,
dass es etwas mehr aufgefahren ist,
dass der Urin sehr stark extrem riecht.
Aber das ist alles.
Okay.
Und gibt es irgendwelche Farbeveränderungen?
Vielleicht.
Ja, sehr dunkel.
Dunkel.
In der letzten Zeit trinken Sie genug Wasser?
Also, ich trinke immer so ungefähr 1 Liter am Tag.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nee, übel ist mir nicht.
Okay.
Herr Müller.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas für Ihre aktuellen Anamnese
etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ich möchte nur, dass die Schmerzen aufhören,
weil das ist jetzt ziemlich lästig.
In den 2 Tagen tut das jetzt unaufhaltig.
Sie sollen mal aufhören.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Aber nach der körperlichen Untersuchung geben wir Ihnen
natürlich ein Schmerzmittel.
Aber erst mal, ich muss Sie körperlich untersuchen,
um die Schmerzen genau zu lokalisieren.
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende unserer Gespräche
aushalten könnten, dann wäre das wirklich gut.
Okay.
Ja, ich denke, das muss schon gehen.
Dann leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen wie Diabetes-Fukerkrankheit
oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, ich habe einen Diabetes.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette ein, ja.
Okay.
Was für Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Das ist eine Metformin, 1.000 Milligramm,
die ich einmal morgens, einmal abends einnehmen muss.
Und seit wann haben Sie Diabetes?
Seit mehr als 20 Jahren.
Okay.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine anderen Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Haben Sie wichtige Vorerkrankungen gehabt?
Nein, nicht für Sie.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Wie meinen Sie das in der Familie?
Sie meinen in der Blutverwandtschaft?
Genau, bei meinem Vater oder bei der Mutter.
Also beim Vater weiß ich nicht, der ist im Krieg gestorben.
Die Mutter, die hat mal mit dem Blutdruck zu tun gehabt.
Aber sonst weiß ich nichts.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht mehr geht mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bruder oder Ihre Kinder sind auch gesund?
Also meine Kinder sind gesund und Geschwister habe ich keine,
weil, wie gesagt, mein Vater im Krieg gefallen ist.
Okay.
Also Herr Müller, haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Also können Sie Blutdurchschlafen und einschlafen?
Schlafstörungen habe ich keine.
Ne, weder beim Einschlafen noch durchschlafen.
Es geht alles wunderbar.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut. Ich kann normal essen.
Das ist gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, hin und wieder ist er mal fest.
Dann habe ich auch mal Blähungen.
Aber mein Arzt sagt mir, das macht das mit Formin.
Okay, sagt man, haben Sie?
Also das hat schon seit einigen Jahren,
solange ich mit Formin einnehme.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie nicht belastet?
Oder mental belastet?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Also haben Sie Stress in der Familie?
Oder Probleme?
Sieht dem nicht, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, kein Stress.
Außer mit Formin?
Nehmen Sie Regie, medikamente ein oder bei Bedarf?
Nein, ich nehme keine.
Okay.
Rafeln Sie, Herr Müller?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, gar nicht.
Oder nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nein, überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen, wenn Sie nicht mehr auf dem Kopf kommen,
dann haben Sie die Alergie.
Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Ja, ich kann Paprika nicht vertragen.
Und so im Frühjahr habe ich so Birken-Allergie, das ist dabei alles.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wie diese Allergie sich äußert?
Also wenn Birken,
im Frühjahr, wenn die Birken glühen,
dann habe ich Schnupfen und meine Nase läuft.
Und wenn ich Paprika nehme,
kriege ich sofort Luftnot und Yukreiz.
Und das darf ich nicht.
Das sage ich dann aber immer Bescheid.
Okay.
Herr Müller, meinerseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie dazu etwas ergänzen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, nein.
Dann erstes.
Ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann abnehmen.
Dann würde ich auch bei Ihnen eine Ultraschall durchführen.
Bauch Ultraschall.
Ja.
Also gegebenenfalls können wir auf ein CT, Bauch CT,
veranlassen, CT veranlassen.
Okay.
Ja.
Wenn Sie nicht mehr Fragen haben,
bitte warten Sie ein bisschen im Wartesma.
Dann komme ich Ihnen wieder gleich. Okay?
Ja, na klar. Gerne.
In der Gruppe gibt es noch Fragen?
Anscheinend nicht.
Okay.
Dann nur 30 Sekunden für die Vorbereitung.
Ich bin bereit.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja.
Okay.
Er heißt Manfred Müller.
Er ist 76 Jahre alt.
Er klagt über Abdominalschmerzen.
Er hat 5 Tage rechten Planke.
Also beim Wasserlassen hat sie die Suri.
Hat er die Suri.
Abdominalschmerzen sind krampfartig.
Erster Mal aufgetreten.
Er ist auf der Leufe der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient fühlt sich warm an,
aber er hat die Temperatur nicht gemessen.
Und als weitere Beschwerden nennt er schlechter Geruch beim Wasserlassen.
Er ist auf der Leufe der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Er hat die Urin.
Er ist auf die Vitativen.
Er ist unauf temptation auf Fiber.
Er ist đâu mit Approxen discouraged.
Nicht raucher, er hat kein Alkohol und er ist allergisch gegen Paprika und Birken.
Wir sind alles.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einem Nephrolitiasis aus.
Also das kann auch eine Neph... Pylonephritis sein?
Mhm. Also, Sie können sagen, Sie gehen von einer Infektion des Haarm-Trakters aus und vermutlich auch eine aufsteigende Nierenbeckenentzündung, sagen wir im Deutschen dazu, oder Pylonephritis.
Aber versuchen Sie auch immer wieder mal deutsche Begriffe mit reinzunehmen, damit der Prüfer dann auch weiß, dass Sie das beherrschen.
Also eine aufsteigende Nierenbeckenentzündung, danach hört sich das ja an.
Ob das jetzt tatsächlich eine Nephrolitiasis ist, kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Aber, was der Mann hat, ist, der hat Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen, Brennen und dauerhafte Stechende bis leicht krampfartige Schmerzen, aber keine Kuliken.
Und bei Nephrolitiasis hätte ich ja Kuliken erwartet.
Also müssen Sie schon genau angehen.
Okay, das ist ja wahrscheinlich Pylonephritis, dann Nierenbeckenentzündung, genau.
Differenzial diagnostisch, kommt zum Beispiel auch Zistitis oder Scholesistitis, oder nie?
Ja, das war es.
Der hat ja keine Kuliken, genau.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, das kann natürlich auch irgendwie der Darm sein in dem Bereich, dass er dort im Darmbereichen ein Problem hat.
Wir wissen es nicht genau, aber genau würden Sie es wissen, wenn Sie natürlich einen Ultraschall gemacht haben.
Und wenn Sie jetzt vermuten, dass der jetzt eine Infektion der Hahnwege hat, wie finden Sie das relativ rasch raus?
Urin-Test?
Ja, wonach schauen Sie da?
Ein Urin-Sticks, sagt man ja.
Urin-Sticks.
Was sehen Sie im Sticks, was für einen Hahnwege-Infekt spricht?
Also können wir Lykots-Tools oder eine Lykots-Tourie?
Lykots-Tourie.
Noch gibt es etwas, aber vergessen.
Den Nitrit-Test, genau, Nitrit.
Weil die Bakterien im Urin können Nitrit umsetzen und dann wird daraus positiv.
Also der Nitrit-Test ist beweisend eigentlich, dass jemand einen Hahnwege-Infekt hat.
Lykots-Titten von 500 oder so plus Nitrit-Positiv, dann haben Sie ganz sicher einen Hahnwege-Infekt.
Und jetzt machen Sie anschließend noch die körperliche Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie dabei?
Was machen Sie bei der Untersuchung?
Also die wichtigste ist, Perkutieren, ich die Flanke, meine Flanke.
Ja.
Oder was macht man da?
Was macht man bei der Niere?
Nicht einfach Perkutieren.
Perkutieren ist der Lager.
Palpation?
Ja, Palpation auch nicht.
Man klopft richtig drauf, mit der Faust draufhauen.
Ja, man sagt auch einen Klopfschmerz über den Nierenlager.
Also positiver Klopfschmerz über den Nierenlager.
Das ist ein deutscher Begriff.
Also Klopfen ist nicht ein Perkution?
Nein, Perkution ist, wenn Sie Ihren Finger...
da hinlegen, das ist das.
Aber hier, H, nehmen Sie richtig die Faust und Klopfen drauf.
Und wenn der Mann dann aufspringt und wird dann sauer, weil es weh getan hat,
dann ist das positiv.
Mit einer Perkution kriegen Sie da nichts raus.
Genau, okay.
Ja.
Also der Klopfschmerz ist positiv.
Der Mann hat einen Klopfschmerz über den Nierenlager.
Und er hat eine Leukozitorie und den Nitritis positiv.
Und damit haben Sie eigentlich den Verdacht, dass der einen Harnwixinfekt mit Pylonefrittis hat.
Und Sicherheit, machen Sie jetzt noch einen Ultraschall.
Und was sehen Sie denn da im Ultraschall, wenn Sie die Niere mit einer Pylonefrittis angucken?
Also können wir die Verlückung der Nierenband sehen.
Nein, nicht so ganz, sondern im Nierenbecken sehen Sie,
dass das Nierenbecken so ein bisschen aufgetrieben ist
und auch das Paranküm so ein bisschen auffällig dick erscheint.
Und was sollten Sie in dem Falle noch machen?
Sie haben ja nur einen Urin Sticks gemacht,
aber zur Sicherheit sollten Sie noch etwas machen.
Blutabnahme ist wichtig.
Ja, Blutabnahme, aber auch zu einem Parameter.
Ah, Kultur. Urin Kultur.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also eine Urin Kultur ist noch richtig.
Sie haben zwar den Sticks gemacht, aber nehmen noch eine Kultur ab.
Damit wenn die Therapie nicht anspricht,
dass Sie dann eine antibiogrammgerechte Therapie machen können.
Ja.
Gut. Und jetzt haben Sie Blut abgenommen und da sehen Sie,
sein CRP ist bei 25.
Und der hat Leukotys von 15.000.
Und Sie haben seine Temperatur gemessen.
Der Mann hat 38,7 Temperatur.
Als erstes gibt es ein...
Erst mal, wir müssen diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und die Antipyretikum, also geben als Parol,
in die Vene als Infusion.
Dann können wir auch intravenös, also als Infusion Antipyretikum, geben.
Also, was man machen muss,
bevor Sie den aufnehmen stationär,
müssen Sie dem sofort ein Antipyretikum anhängen.
Also bei solchen Sachen nicht stationär aufnehmen und auf station was anhängen,
sondern Sie müssen dem sofort in der Notaufnahme ein Antipyretikum anhängen.
Was geben Sie denn?
Was würden Sie dann kalkulieren, was für ein Keim erwarten Sie?
Und was würden Sie dann da als Antipyretikum geben?
Ziftreaktion?
Ja, muss man nicht.
Ziftreaktion ist zwar gut, das ist ein Drittgeneration,
zur Fallung Spurin, aber hier in Deutschland sagt man,
soll man das nicht mal machen, weil das eben zu viele Resistenzen hervorruft.
Der Mann, der hat keinen Katheter,
der lebt nicht in einem Heim, der hat keinen chronischen Hahnwilfsinfekt.
Von daher können Sie eben ganz normal auch Penicilline geben.
Sie können dem Ampicillin Dolbachfarm geben
oder aber auch Zweitgenerationen, Zephalosporin,
zum Beispiel Zephyroxem, können Sie dem geben,
weil Sie erwarten ganz normale empfindliche Keime.
Typrofluxazin kann man zwar geben,
würde ich aber in dem Falle jetzt erst mal nicht machen.
Ich denke mit, und zwar auch deshalb,
weil der Mann ist auch nicht jung und bei älteren Leuten
können Ziprofluxazin-Medikamente
auch mal paradoxe Reaktionen,
so delirantes Syndrome manchmal auslösen.
Deshalb gebe ich eher nicht Zipro IV,
sondern ich gebe dann eher Ampicillin Dolbachfarm.
Und wenn Sie das Antibiogramm bekommen,
dann sehen Sie ja, ob Ihr Medikament auch wirksam war,
ob Sie das dann weiter fortführen können
oder ob Sie das zum Beispiel umstellen müssen.
Gut. Und was schätzen Sie?
Wie lange müssten Sie das Antibiotikum geben?
Wie viele Tage so?
14 Tage?
Das ist zu viel.
Nee, ich würde sagen so fünf bis sieben Tage.
Urale, ja.
Nein, das ist IV oder Urale, Antibiotikum nach der...
Nee, IV, weil es kommt ja fast skeptisch,
dem kann man nicht.
Wenn man, eins müssen Sie wissen,
wenn Sie jemanden stationär aufnehmen,
ins Krankenhaus, dann geben Sie immer IV.
Wenn Sie jemanden Ural geben, dann sagt der MDK,
das ist das Kontrollgremium der Krankenhaut,
die sagen, wenn jemand Tabletten schlucken kann,
das geht auch zu Hause.
Dazu muss man niemanden im Krankenhaus aufnehmen.
Nicht vergessen, wenn Sie jemanden im Krankenhaus
einen Antibiotikum geben, dann geben Sie das IV besser.
Ja?
Ja.
Gut. Also, der hat eine Pylone Fritzis
und Sie werden das dann auch merken,
sobald Sie mit dem Antibiotikum beginnen,
entzwiebert der Mensch,
die Schmerzen werden auch weniger.
Das geht relativ rass fast.
Ja.
Und innerhalb weniger Tage haben die Schmerzen so nachgelassen,
dass sie diesen Menschen dann nach fünf bis sieben Tagen
auch schon entlassen können.
Den können sie nach Hause schicken.
Okay.
Und was sie machen können, so nach drei, vier Tagen
können sie nochmal den Urin kontrollieren,
nochmal mit dem Urinsticks, ob die Leucocytorie weg ist,
ob dieser positive Nitrit noch nachweisbar ist oder nicht.
Und dann haben Sie Ihren Erfolg damit schon mal gemessen.
Und zweitens sehen Sie, dass der CRP-Wert runtergeht,
dass die Leucocytose weg ist,
dass sein Blutbild sich normalisiert.
Und dann haben Sie diesen Menschen schon gut geholfen.
Okay.
Sollen wir nach der Entlassung
eine orale Antibiotik, Antibiotikum geben?
Ne, braucht er nicht.
Nein, macht er nicht.
Nur wenn er immer noch einen Rest befunden hätte,
wenn sein CRP noch hoch wäre
und wenn er immer noch ein bisschen Leucocytonemorinen hätte,
dann hätte ich gesagt, man kann vielleicht noch
zwei, drei Tage oral die Antibiotika-Therapie
zu Hause fortführen.
Aber so nach fünf bis sieben Tagen
müsste das eigentlich ausbehandelt sein.
Okay.
Ja?
Also das sieht man auch aus.
Vor allem ältere Leute und Diabetika.
Warum?
Weil durch diesen Zucker, durch die Glucoserie
werden die Hahnwege empfindlich für Bakterien.
Und bei Männern kann es dann auch
zu einer aufsteigenden Pylone Frittes kommen.
Das ist die Gefahr dabei.
Mhm.
Gut.
Und was man bei dem natürlich machen kann,
wenn Sie jetzt wissen, der nimmt mit Formin ein
und der hat jetzt einen Hahnwegeinfekt,
können Sie auch den Zucker mal kontrollieren.
Indem Sie einmal schauen, was macht sein HBR1C Wert,
ist er damit gut eingestellt.
Und Sie haben ja auch einen Urinstix gemacht
und dort müssten Sie dann sehen,
dass auch seine Glucose sehr, sehr hoch ist.
Mhm.
Und das wird ja auch teilweise in Zahlen angegeben.
Wenn da die Glucose mit 1000 oder so angegeben wird,
dann wissen Sie automatisch,
sein Zucker ist nicht gut eingestellt.
Sie haben zwar jetzt den Hahnwegeinfekt behandelt,
auch die Pylone Frittes,
aber der muss auch noch mal zu Diabetologen.
Wahrscheinlich reicht dann die Metformin nicht aus
und die Therapie muss weiter angepasst werden.
Mhm.
Ja?
Ja.
Gut.
Super.
Noch Fragen?
Fragen?
Von den anderen noch Fragen?
Ja, nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch nichts mehr zu sagen.
Okay.
Vielen Dank für heute.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, es war ein bisschen hilfreich,
dass man dann auch so ein Blick hinbekommen kann,
wie man damit dann ganz schnell oder ganz regulär umgehen kann.
Und ich wünsche viel Glück.
Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Dieser Feller kommt ja oft.
Deswegen, dass es eine gute Training für uns.
Ja, danke schön.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Tschüss.
Schönen Abend.